des événements importants ont retenu
l'attention cette semaine notamment le
rapport de la commission de vérité et
réconciliation sur les pensionnats
autochtones mais d'abord bien sûr cette
importante nouvelle qui tombe ce soir le
sénateur pierre hugues boisvenu qui se
retire du caucus conservateur nouvelle
qui survient au moment où le
vérificateur général vient tout juste de
remettre à la chambre haute son rapport
sur les dépenses 10 sénateurs tâche à
michel daniel bonsoir daniel je vais
commencer avec vous stephen rapp eux
étaient tellement fiers d'avoir recruté
pierre bois venu c'était le visage de la
loi et l'ordre
et là évidemment c'est fait l'objet
d'une enquête de la grc
qu'est ce que c'est non seulement il
fait l'objet d'une enquête mais il doit
quitter le sénat temporairement nous
dit-on le temps que tout ça redevienne à
la normale si jamais ça redevient la
normale à écouter à il ya eu les os à
cause aussi aujourd'hui il ya eu claude
carignan l'ancien conseiller de la dq
sur lequel on misait beaucoup
candidature prestigieuse et cetera
pierre hugues boisvenu avant cela il y
avait eu les deux faits warden et
parisot et aidera tout pardon à
l'opposition le dit et le répète depuis
quelques jours la question est encore
plus pertinente ce soir se pose de façon
plus aiguë de quelle sorte de jugement a
fait preuve s'ils veulent un peu quand
il a nommé ces gens au sénat est ce
qu'ils savent s il a vérifié sks que
comment se fait-il qu'on se retrouve
dans cette situation là c'est
dommageable c'est dévastateur à ça le
sera aussi pour les libéraux parce qu'il
ya des sénateurs libéraux il ya au moins
six qui sont dans la liste ceux qui sont
référés à la grc
c'est dommageable et c'est dommageable
pour monsieur a un peu vous pouvez déjà
avoir les deux partis d'opposition s'en
donnaient à coeur joie
même si je sais trop d'eau devra faire
preuve de certaines une certaine retenue
même si ses 10 ans et de ses sénateurs
libéraux ça reste que ce sont des
libéraux ouais aujourd'hui plusieurs
d'entre eux qui sont visés ont dit que
c'était pas mis de l'argent dans leurs
poches là mais ce rapport qui vise
justement à léo housakos d'achat
il vient d'être nommé à la tête du sénat
au président du sénat alors
qu'apparemment on savait qu'elle avait
peut-être des doutes sur ce sur lui
alors pourquoi est-ce que si vous nous
rappeler a pris ce risque là de le
nommer président
mais messieurs housakos même quand il a
été interrogé ce matin il ne pensait pas
qu'il était sur la fameuse liste de 21
c'est gens là avaient reçu des lettres
c'est vrai indiquant qu'il y avait une
possibilité dire et d'irrégularités
selon le vérificateur général dans le
cas de monsieur uzak os et un contrat
d'environ 6000 $ qui est en question
qu'il avait octroyé à une tierce partie
on ne sait pas tous les détails c'est
sûr que le premier ministre a nommé des
gens qui sont sur la liste mais comme
vous avez dit aussi plein de gens qui ne
le sont pas qui n'ont pas été nommés par
monsieur harper et qui étaient soit de
l'ancien régime libéral où on ne sait
pas exactement si les conservateurs
présentent des conservateurs qui ont été
nommés avant alors dans le cas de messi
ou sacoche je pense que on va voir on en
a pas le rapport on sait pas exactement
les détails de ce qui est allégué etc
des allégations aussi les règles du
sénat ne sont pas claires cependant
c'est j'ai jamais une bonne nouvelle
pour le gouvernement et je pense que
monsieur aux accords devraient se
retirer de la position qu'il a pour
essayer de corriger ces choses ne
pourrai pas siéger comme le président du
du sénat sur le comité qui veut
régulariser le sénat quand il est nommé
sur la licence déplacements comment ils
peuvent faire le ménage alors qu'ils
sont cette affaire il devrait être
accusé
je suis accusée de sa wii michel ben
écoutez c'est clair que c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle pour monsieur un peu
c'est à tout le moins un manque de
vigilance un manque de jugement et on a
l'impression qu'il ya un système
pratiquement organisé au sénat on mais
on verra effectivement s'il y avait dans
le rapport mais c'est embêtant pour les
libéraux je crois comprendre que six des
neuf sénateurs dont le aussi va être
transférée à la grc sont des libéraux
brassé pas d'une bonne nouvelle pour les
libéraux non plus et je vous dirais qu'à
la limite ça va bientôt devenir le
problème de tous les canadiens il arrive
t on à un sénat monsieur harper ne veut
plus combler les postes je sais pas
parce qu'après d'avoir accordé par
surprise
monsieur trudeau a exclu les sénateurs
du beirut son caucus
monsieur monsieur moquer bon il n'y a
pas de sénateur néo démocrates mais lui
veut carrément abolir le sénat a annoncé
on l'a vu avec la cour suprême qu'on
peut pas abolir le sénat sans l'accord
des provinces on veut pas rouvrir la
constitution parce qu'on sait qu'on ne
sait pas ce qui va arriver un coucou on
va ouvrir ce panier de crabes là alors
qu'est ce qu'on va faire avec le sénat a
vraiment donné ça va devenir un problème
national
le plus grande ironie la plus grande
ironie si vous me permettez c'est que
quand il faudra peut t'arriver politique
souvenez-vous l'une l'un de ses grands
objectifs c'était la réforme du sénat
rappelez-vous ce fameux sénat trois élus
égale efficace il s'est battu pour cette
réforme
il s'est rendu compte que c'était
probablement impossible de réformer le
sénat il s'est lui aussi lancé dans les
nominations partisanes et là on ne parle
plus de relance du sénat ya déjà ce soir
ici à ottawa qui se demandent est ce que
le sénat va survivre mais comme le dit
michel l'abolir assez s'engager dans des
débats constitutionnels qui n'attirent
pas beaucoup de monde en ce moment
mais ce que le sénat peut survivre
achats mais le sénat oui peut survivre
sauf que il ya aussi le jugement de la
cour suprême qui dit n'importe quel
premier ministre ne veut pas laisser
jamais ouvert les sièges et on y revient
maintenant de nomination qui devrait
être fait pour combler les sièges on
peut pas tuer le sénat simplement en
nommant personnes à cette chambre là
alors il faut un moment donné qu'il ya
une forme d'action la seule façon
vraiment c'est de passer par la
constitution
mais ce n'est pas vraiment une personne
qui aime convoquer les premiers
ministres mais si les premiers ministres
seraient d'accord à six mois des
élections
actuellement ça va se faire dans les six
mois mais ça va faire un débat c'est sûr
lors des élections qui va avoir un
propres propos plan pour corriger les
excès qu'on voit mais ouvrir la
constitution monsieur couillard qui
peuvent vraiment apprécié de se lancer
dans des négociations constituerait le
gamin dit que si ça arrive il va arriver
avec sa liste de demandes est là
ils arrivent à se dresser et les eaux
toxiques des banques et des groupes
c'est une boîte de pandore personnes
veulent ouvrir parce que sinon on les
ouvre surtout voilà bon alors on va
passer maintenant à cet autre événement
quand même qui a retenu l'attention
cette semaine c'est le rapport de cette
commission vérité et réconciliation qui
a été déposée avant qu'on en dise que
j'aimerais qu'on voit quelques images
cannes a créé par son père
je suis d'accord que ce fût de génocide
culturel mais l'important maintenant
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on en fait il faut
que notre génération commence à réparer
les torts pour l'avenir si on ne le fait
pas avec notre coeur en faisant au moins
avec ma tête ait 20 ans rick
vous aurez remarqué ces images deux
images marquantes celle du ministre des
affaires indiennes bernard valcourt qui
est resté assis cette semaine lorsque le
président la commission de vérité et
réconciliation a recommandé la tenue
d'une enquête sur les femmes autochtones
disparues
et puis stephen harper qui n'a pas parlé
lors de la cérémonie de clôture de la
commission alors laquelle possibilité de
réconciliation maintenant qu'on connaît
la vérité sur les pensionnats
autochtones
michel est ce que mon sens pas beaucoup
d'enthousiaste de la part du
gouvernement fédéral
est ce que il a la volonté politique
selon vous d'amorcer cette
réconciliation va écouter parler d'un
manque d'enthousiastes un euphémisme
ces salaires de désintérêt total écoutez
je pense que monsieur harper
personnellement ne pas un grand intérêt
pour la question comme pouvait en avoir
par exemple paul martin et d'autre part
écoutez je pense qu'il faut bien le dire
il n'y a pas non plus grosse pression de
la part de la population je pense pour
régler le problème autochtone
certainement pas de la base
conservatrice dans l ouest mais je pense
des canadiens en général il faut le
reconnaître même au québec
vous savez à toutes les fois qu'il ya
des cohabitation avec les autochtones et
les non autochtones que ce soit les
morts que ça soit l'issue nous ça se
passe pas tellement bien alors je pense
que c'est bon exemple
oui exactement il ya des beaux exemples
comme ça de commandes et de
collaboration officielle mais dans la
vie de tous les jours le ceux qui
habitent près dé réserve mohawk ou
encore sur la côte nord ça se passe pas
très bien alors je pense pas qu'il ya un
élan d'enthousiasmé dans la population
pour dire écoutez sa patte bon ça il va
falloir une éducation sérieuse des
canadiens non autochtones et que des
recommandations d'ailleurs le film
s'attache à sk une volonté politique du
gouvernement
valdes amorcé un peu un dialogue quelque
chose mais il s'est un peu ironique
parce que le gouvernement fédéral a agi
sur plusieurs plans en ce qui a trait au
système de réserve les droits des femmes
par exemple de faire des plaintes aux
commissions des droits de la personne
les droits aussi à la propriété
personnelle sur les réserves qui sont
qui ont été chargées qui sont étaient
très peu et aussi essayer de faire du
développement économique
parce que finalement c'est par cette
voie là je pense que vraiment les
autochtones vont s'affirmer le problème
c'est que le legs des écoles
résidentielles sicot logique aussi et
sociale est tellement difficile à
surmonter pour ces individus qui ont été
touchés par sa et leurs enfants et leurs
petits enfants
et alors c'est quelque chose qui est
très très difficile mais ça commence là
où le gouvernement a commencé et sauf
que à cause de leur position sur la
moquette ou le refus à tenir les
enquêtes sur les femmes à cause de la
froideur que monsieur harper démontré
envers ces dossiers là c'est très
difficile de faire un dialogue parce que
il n'ya pas la volonté politique des
côtes et des autochtones pour dealé avec
le gouvernement de monsieur rappeur est
ce qu'il aurait dû s'exprimer selon vous
à la commission quand même moi je pense
que oui je pense que il faut commencer
quelque part ça aurait été une façon de
commencer ce dialogue ou de montrer de
bonnes volontés peut-être il se sentait
mal à l'aise je ne sais pas ou ne
voulaient pas est très critiqué mais
c'est un dossier qui est important suis
pas d'accord qui a aucune volonté
politique dans l'ouest en particulier la
moitié des premières nations sont en bas
de l'âge de 15 ans c'est une population
très jeune une population qui va causer
des problèmes sociaux pour non seulement
pour eux-mêmes et tout le monde s'ils
n'ont pas les outils pour s'affirmer
économiquement et de façon éducation et
tout ça c'est très important de régler
c'est aussi daniel comment expliquez
vous avez suivi
affaires autochtones depuis longtemps à
voir comment expliquer l'attitude du
gouvernement
écoutez à au tout début quand la loi sur
les indiens et on parlait monsieur
khouya aujourd'hui qui disait il
faudrait absolument la moderniser cela
s'appelait cette voie là au tout début
ça s'appelait l'acte fourvoyant à
l'émancipation des sauvages émancipation
voulais dire à ce moment la simulation
génocide culturel je pense que
l'expression est très juste est ce que
les choses ont beaucoup changé depuis a
pas beaucoup on dépense je retrouve
manche et cinq milliards deux heures par
année 8 milliards de 7,9 millions de
dollars par année pour les autochtones
chaque fois qu'il ya un problème on
saupoudre un peu plus d'argent quand
paul martin pensait avoir trouvé la
recette du siècle avec les accords de
kelowna ça propose encore une fois
d'ajouter 5 milliards au budget des
affaires autochtones
il ya mille ouais y'a un fonctionnaire
du ministère des affaires indiennes
aujourd'hui 20% des réserves qui
fonctionne très très bien qu'ils sont
des modèles il ya 1 60% de réserve où ça
fonctionne à peu près normalement il ya
un autre vin pour ça aussi absolument
catastrophique
il ya chez les autochtones et ça pu
remonter au pensionnat ça te remonter il
ya une raison cette espèce de
résignation de se laisser vivre le
gouvernement parce que ils ne croient
plus aux solutions des blancs et parce
que pas de volonté politique c'est vrai
pour ces veinards feu c'était vrai sous
pierre trudeau il a essayé n'a pas été
capable de rien faire brian mulroney a
essayé une arrière fait jean chrétien
s'est toujours targué d'avoir
d'excellentes relations avec les
autochtones il rien qui a changé par là
qu'il a été au pouvoir
ça reste un problème considérable devant
lequel tous les politiciens que j'ai
connus sont complètement dépourvu michel
comment expliquer cette attitude du
gouvernement
un peu comme je le disais tantôt le peu
d'intérêt personnel le manque mais c'est
pas parce que la population réclame pas
des changements qu'un gouvernement doit
pas prendre d'initiatives dans d'enfer
c'est son rôle d'autre part écoutez
monsieur kouyaté iphone pour régler un
problème il faut d'abord reconnaître son
existence michel couillard débuté il ya
un problème de génocide culturel lors
appelons un chat un chat
ce à quoi on assiste et si c'est
vraiment ça c'est une tentative
d'éradication d'une écriture d'une
langue d'une identité ce sera chez les
enfants tout à fait c'est ça et génocide
culturel je crois comprendre que
monsieur trudeau et monsieur moquait
aussi je parle ce sont près de
reconnaître il le début de la solution
c'est de reconnaître qu'ils ont un
problème
d'autre part c'est pas un problème
strictement de politiciens c'est un
problème social il va falloir que la
population en soit consciente et ça
commence je trouve que monsieur
couillard avait raison ça commence dans
les écoles on a tous des enfants non
voilées manuel qui sont qui sont assez
longs ma part des autochtones mais on en
parle comme des gens qui ont construit
des longues maison qui ont fait pousser
du blé d'inde et qui ont fumé du tabac
et en arrière fond il ya toujours cette
idée que dans le fond on est arrivé pour
les civilisés alors ça c'est une c'est
une vision qu'il faut changer et il faut
aussi qu'on apprenne à nos enfants que
ça fait 200 ans qu on est violente on
les exploite
on essaie de les assimiler de force ça
fait partie de la réalité et il va
falloir qu'on accepte ce serait une
bonne façon de commencer justement à
amorcer ce dialogue mais c'est
malheureusement tout le temps qu'on a
déjà
merci beaucoup à vous trois on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine pour notre
dernière de la saison
enfin peu un bilan de ce qui s'est passé
merci beaucoup 3